alright guys so I figured out where the
[ __ ] I am and I'm not gonna lie this
took me so so much longer than it should
have and I think if you'd have a lot of
problems getting lost in this game but
can we just take a moment to appreciate
the music in the background so like rah
rah rah rah rah all right controllers on
let's go ha so yeah I'm in this elevator
that's slightly to the left this is what
I was supposed to get ridiculous
seriously I would have been walking out
outside around outside doing nothing for
such a long time now I should mention
that i just saved and then walked around
until i saw this and then reloaded so i
don't actually know if this is the right
way to go like aside from seeing that
car I have no idea what I'm doing can't
go through on foot that doesn't make
sense those are just like sheets of
plastic hello all right
I think that I gotta look for someone
down here I'm thinking that that piece
of paper that i found before where I put
it no not the cat with the cap back no
not the safe that thing I think that I
need to do something with that because
why would I just have a piece of paper
that doesn't do anything this isn't
Skyrim this isn't your relevant
inventory game I don't know what that
means but all right we just walking
around is he still walking the a stood
on I don't know where I'm going moon
just walking around a little bit maybe I
was just supposed to see that and then
I'm supposed to go back up with
something ah hello things yes I'm all
about things this looks good there's a
little door back here it's going here
okay wait is this like a male's toilet
does it say men let's do it no service
that's a butt oh my god i didn't expect
sales agent even usually don't come on
his part of the garage uh yeah I'm Manny
collabera Manny calavera my c sub
glottis I don't get many visitors but
that sounds good got a message for a mr.
calavera a driver said that mr. Hurley
said then he could have the rest of the
day off Domino sent my driver home yeah
wasn't that wise I feel like that's
probably not true um sure that looks
great is that a German name oh no my
roots yeah I don't know why I thought
your germination soil I am in El you
know that makes a lot of sense here it
summoned up from the land of the dead
itself and given one from you're clearly
not human skill one desire
to drive or to change oil and a job
timing belts if no driving jobs are open
really passionate about that okay uh
that one looks like I need a new driver
oh I would agree with that yes you do
yes hey you a driver me oh no no okay i
just asked that question why not ask
again now um yeah do it come on Gladys I
need you to be my driver no I s dead of
driving I'm oh yes what repeat after me
I oh [ __ ] hey I never said I was too fat
for the ladies just the cars the ladies
like me just fine I bet they do I bet
they do Gladys um okay yeah screw the
rules come with me no getting in trouble
is fun we're in the land of the dead man
out where you're already in the land of
the dead okay that one you're not to be
the cars are just too small hey who an
idea that sounds good idea I could alter
your car just a pitcher just a quick
torch job to let out the seams you know
I'm not allowed to bother filing cars
without a work order pro k I say you're
gonna give me one job a work order huh
let's do that I can't torch anything
bigger than a cigarette without one of
the air signed by the boss himself hey
that's my line let's do it people to
sign back in a snap yeah too small I'm
not know everything around here is junk
tubes I just made this dude's day it was
so happy about that you are beautiful
Gladys you not German someone from the
dead guy that's actually a really good
compliment though you want not too big
everything else is just too small you
beautiful beautiful thing and I mean I
can understand everything else being
tiny world skeletons we don't even have
any [ __ ] muscle like really what what
is what am I I is even composed oh look
how big the thighs look how how are you
so broad you are literally a sack of
beautiful bones beautiful bones not you
know not gonna get into more body image
[ __ ] here alright so let's go to Eva and
use her hole punch hey no I want to use
a whole pond okay there we go if I
really need the pasta sign this work
order I'll give it good mr. kopel i've
got Manny calavera out here to see you
didn't I say no interruptions today
sorry
now maybe tomorrow anywhere what now oh
ok let's try and go back out this way oh
alright I don't know what's you oh why
don't I just do because of the camera
angles of these games you know sometimes
like [ __ ] like this can just be really
really confusing so I'm just heading up
the back of the whole way now yeah
alright that's what's happened I thought
that it was like facing me the other way
but it's never mind never mind i'm not
gonna even try to explain my failures
there we go in here yet ya know all
right I wonder what I have to do to get
this thing sign he's not signing
anything today hmm
I don't know um
uh I feel like this is gonna happen a
lot like okay I really do both love and
hate when games do this I love that it
doesn't hand everything to you like
games back in the day when this came out
was so much hotter and there was so much
time I spent getting confused worries
now they just kind of like full speed
you everything fo and i love i love this
kind of stuff making you explore and and
especially when it's come accompanied by
lovely music and awesome dialogue it's
great but um yeah I just get really
frustrated you know they spent a lot of
time doing nothing and there has to be
something to do here and I get through
here huge that's what she said oh hey
this is near yes
this is something I couldn't do this
before look at the little animation in
the middle oh my god you're a brave man
is there some kind of platforming mmm no
little dead buddy did I just break into
my own office no this isn't my office
yeah okay nice and green there's all
this stuff if I go out that way oh [ __ ]
so I'm not supposed to be in here around
in here I'd be very surprised if someone
didn't see you would love to search
doughnuts are poisoning what so I'm not
meant to be in here I don't know how to
get to the poison even him hello it
looks like Don's rigged his computer to
automatically answer his inner person
not even here oh uh yes i'll just change
his autos that one year yes amazing and
then go back to work yes he's clearly
not even busy he's not even here okay
okay I'm so worried about dying right
now oh oh can I I don't know you okay
buddy I don't know why I'm worried about
dying I've already dead we've been all
over this all right back inside the
building I ok i can't believe that i
found that so quickly i'm not gonna lie
that so i've learnt things here right
what I've learned is I was like okay it
has to be a point to that piece of paper
that I was given and I'd still don't
think that was because I ended up
getting a new work order ya know maybe
there wasn't but ok let's just assume
disregarding that my original logic is
flawed that everything that exists in
the game is there for a reason so maybe
that car is also there for a reason and
I will be able to interact with it
eventually and like you know when I
meant that before that rope I was like
hmm
surely this is hanging down for some
reason so keep that in mind and then
hopefully we won't spend too much time
doing absolutely [ __ ] nothing no it
would be fantastic wouldnít okay can I
use your hole punch yes if I really need
the pasta side to this corner I'll give
it a shot yes mr. copal mr. calavera has
something out here that he says he needs
your signature on you'll have to excuse
him Manny it's gonna be a really hot
fast sure he got in there today he's not
even in there ever rest I got no he's
not even in there well we all have our
secrets
that got seductive very quickly damn
what is this bioshock infinite ok now
it's weird hey it's me and we're gonna
right oh [ __ ] yes look the COS are just
too small my buddy you can do it i
believe in you you can do it yeah well
wait this seems good well who we're
doing things accomplished and gongs and
such it's great i gotta walk faster than
this yeah but you couldn't walk through
they little bits of plastic many
excited to see this poisoning well this
is [ __ ] up so what the real log looks
like we go back to the dead don't Wow da
mean what the [ __ ] is this the living
still be oh my god um no [ __ ] what the
hell is happening ok I'm going to save
here this is where we will end this
epping snowed